hey ich bin's roland vom hamburger pc
klar drei fragen wir dich um die erste
wehr was sind deine pläne für die
zukunft sei es auf youtube oder sonst
irgendwo und zweitens welche magst du
bei call of duty am liebsten bei ich
will hier auch gerne
und drittens welchen bieter sturz erstes
gelernt als beatbox sein das wird mich
auch interessieren und auf jeden fall
weiter so daumen hoch tirol an alkohol
dass so eine frage gestellt dass auch
einer von einer treuen kopf
teammitgliedern meine pläne für die
zukunft also erstmal auf jeden fall
studium werden dass es nächstes jahr
fertig und dann mal schauen erst mal auf
jeden fall noch in deutschland bleiben
hier ein bisschen wissens machen und
dann später wahrscheinlich sogar mac
oder nach china auswandern aber erst mal
halt in deutschland meine lieblings
waffe weil call of duty ist die aka aka
sie wird sich einem 16 minuten noch von
ab und zu mal die ump
und die aktie ab und sagen ja ich weiss
und besen lupe aber ich muss machen ich
bin nicht so ein krasses nah wie du
deswegen kann ich so oft du fragst du
welchen bin ich als erst gelernt das war
von reserve firma union und tetris das
war mein erster hattrick falls du nicht
genau weiß wie das geht ich stimme noch
mal ganz kurz an
und so weiß bescheid